- I heard that you do magic.
- Oh, yes.
You know what?
I have a masters in magicology.
- So I heard that you were
saying that you do magic.
I didn't know this.
- I do, I do magic.
It's in my fingers.
- Did you make up
magicology or is it real?
- No, I made it up.
- Okay, okay, I feel like wait.
- Not only did I make it
up, but I only do one trick.
- Okay, great, you know what?
- You wanna see it?
- You're consistent.
Yes!
- You wanna see it?
- Yes, I do.
- I have the trick with me.
- Okay, you have the trick.
- This, I'll tell you where I learned it.
- You're about to just gimme money.
- I had to learn it.
- I will make that disappear.
- Trick.
- No, I can do that too.
I have money to give, everybody gets.
- Ooh!
- Yes.
(Kelly laughing)
- Okay, thank you.
- All right.
- Okay.
- There you go.
- I mean, okay.
- Okay, so.
- What are we doing?
Is this part of the trick?
- This is not part of the trick at all.
You get to go out and
just have drinks together.
- Okay.
- All right.
(audience laughing)
- He's buying us drinks.
(Kelly laughing)
And in LA this shall buy one.
- Yeah.
- It's like.
- Fact.
- What do I have here?
- You have a quarter.
- Okay, is that a quarter?
- That's a quarter.
- All right.
Now listen very carefully.
- Okay.
(glass clinking)
Yeah.
- Is that a quarter?
- That's a quarter.
- Right, that can't be my fingers.
- No.
- Okay, here we go.
- Okay.
- All right.
- Magicology.
- Here we go.
(audience laughing)
- All right.
Okay.
- What are you gonna swallow?
- What?
No.
Okay, now.
Okay, count to three.
- One, two, three.
- How did you do it?
Is it?
- Hello!
(audience cheering)
- Magicology.
- I get the flowers.
- Well, you know what?
I get the money.
- Yeah!
- So it's going in here.
- That's right.